oh the power of the cows good love makes
you happy
[Music]
I wouldn't change one thing
the love
speak to me like a friend
[Music]
teach me like my father taught me how to
live again
[Music]
embrace my Brokenness
thank you
Don't Preach to me a believer in a choir
you're that Hallelujah sweetness
[Music]
so Touch Me Like a Lover
Touch Me Like a Lover
in all my life
please
[Music]
can you play
awesome
[Music]
love
speak to me like a friend
teach me like my father taught me how to
live again
[Music]
embrace my Brokenness
Don't Preach to me a believer in a choir
yeah
[Music]
so Touch Me Like a Lover
touch me like the lover
oh Touch Me Like a Lover
touch me
[Music]
[Applause]